on en vient à la guerre en ukraine les
combats se concentrent dans l'est dans
le donbass mais aussi sur marioupol la
grande ville du sud que les russes
veulent contrôler à tout prix sylvain
rousseau bonjour vous êtes notre envoyé
spécial à kiev la chute de marioupol
serait donc imminente
oui effectivement les choses
s'accélèrent à mario paul qui est à
nouveau l'épicentre de ce set de cette
guerre en ukraine a eu beaucoup de
rumeurs depuis hier beaucoup de fausses
informations beaucoup d'allégations
également très difficile de savoir
exactement où on en est à mario paul le
gouvernement ukrainien vient de
communiquer en expliquant que les russes
intensifier la pression notamment pour
reprendre le port de la ville dans le
sud de la ville sur les bords de la mer
d'azov mais ils ont aussi affirmé qu'ils
la défense ukrainienne tenait toujours
quel que le gouvernement et que les le
chef d'état major des armées étaient
toujours en contact avec ses troupes qui
défendent mario paul contrairement à ce
qui a pu à ce qui a pu être dit hier il
ya également eu ce matin la nuit
dernière des allégations d'utilisation
d'armes chimiques par les russes et le
bataillon azoff qui le premier a fait
état de drones dispersant du gaz sur les
soldats kényans ont déçu
civile des civils et des zones
d'activités dans 8 cas de difficultés
respiratoires alors bien sûr tout cela
est encore impossible à confirmer même
le gouvernement ukrainien le reconnaît
ils ont lancé une enquête pour l'instant
il ne confirme pas cette utilisation
d'armes chimiques les britanniques
également ont tout de suite et les
premières rumeurs lancé une enquête ils
ont même promis des conséquences si cela
devait être avéré même si on ne sait pas
encore quelle forme ces conséquences je
prendrai ce qui est réellement sûr à
mario paul c'est qu'effectivement la
ville va tomber aux mains des russes si
ce n'est pas une question d'heure c'est
une question de jours un vladimir
poutine en a fait une affaire
personnelle dit on ici en ukraine alors
que pour stratégiquement ça n'a plus
vraiment d'intérêt pour les russes la
jonction entre la crimée et les troupes
les territoires occupés à l'est est
désormais largement effectué notre est
cependant contournant
mario pole mais en revanche ce serait un
gros coup au moral à des ukrainiens
alors que l'on annonce de plus en plus
proche la grande bataille pour l'est du
pays et pour le contrôle du dombass et
puisqu'on sait à mario paul aussi ça
c'est une certitude c'est que la ville
est quasiment détruites et que les
cadavres de militaires mais surtout de
civils vont se compter par milliers
peut-être même par dizaines de milliers
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme le
gouvernement ukrainien merci beaucoup
sylvain rousseau vos envoyé spécial
france 24 avec rob personnes à kiev